He was raised at the jedi temple on coruscant.
At the end of the clone wars when the empire
rose to power, he was hidden. Someone took him
from the temple, then his memory becomes dark.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 video for the
full history of the child they gave him a name and
explained where he came from what his history was
how he fits into the canon of the prequel movies
the clone wars the original trilogy so we'll break
it all down there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
and a really strong connection to the prophecy of
the chosen one so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we'll do a new giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know on the video who do you
think is the jedi that rescued him during order
66. careful for spoilers if you have not seen the
mandalorian season 2 episode 5 yet because we'll
be talking about everything that they discussed
during that starting with the big stuff first
so recently during season 2 episode 5 they
revealed that the child baby yoda's real name
was grogu and answered almost every single
question you've ever had about him i was kind of
surprised and not surprised that they went with
a non-why name because the only other member of
yoda's species that we've ever met was yaddle and
she had a name that sounded very similar to yoda
so you kind of wonder if all members of their race
have similar sounding names obviously this also
confirms a little bit about exactly who he is and
how he's related to yoda and potentially yaddle
even after season 2 episode 4 because it seems
like moff gideon has this big cloning plot
involving the kamino facility from attack of the
clones and all the stuff with palpatine's clones
during the movies the clever way that they
reveal his true name was that he told ahsoka
telepathically through the force on the show they
kind of made it seem like he can't speak verbally
he just makes baby noises cooing or burbling
sounds all the time depending on his moods
there had been a lot of questions during season
one but what his speech might sound like if he
actually ever did speak out loud would he have
the same backwards speech that yoda did or would
he speak with regular syntax like everyone else
i like that they didn't answer that question in
the ahsoka episode and because he ages so slowly
no matter how many seasons the mandalorian goes
for unless they do some giant flash forward
in the series finale he's always going to be
this tiny little kid i think they're implying
that he's always going to communicate the way
that he does now just using his body language
and tiny noises and he and mando will just be a
lot like han solo and chewbacca from the original
trilogy even though chewbacca is always speaking
normally in his own language it just sounds like
gibberish to everyone else and han solo just kind
of understands it right now mando has kind of
learned to do the same thing just understanding
grogu's patterns of communication through his
body language it also kind of helps that most
of the time all he's communicating is that he's
hungry or he wants stuff like that's his default
state i'm hungry if you don't get me some food
i'll snatch it for myself but early prediction
i think by the time we get to the later seasons
when his abilities in the force develop a little
more he'll be able to actually push his thoughts
into mando's mind directly and communicate really
really important things that way the really cool
thing that ahsoka told us though is that grogu's
early history goes back many decades to the jedi
temple on coruscant he was there for a long time
canonically he was also born the same year as
anakin skywalker let that sit for a minute and
think about the implications that some straight up
harry potter neville longbottom stuff right there
because they have a chosen one character in both
harry potter and star wars anakin skywalker is the
chosen one of the star wars universe but in the
harry potter canon neville longbottom was born on
the same day as harry potter in voldemort learns
of a prophecy foretelling his death at the hands
of a chosen one who's supposed to be born on the
day that both harry potter and neville longbottom
were born so he had to choose which child to go
after and kill and he just chose harry potter
arbitrarily so it was a self-fulfilling prophecy
he created the chosen one but it was an arbitrary
choice so neville longbottom could have just
as easily been the chosen one so now we have
a similar situation in the star wars universes
that are implying where you have two incredibly
powerful children born around the same time so
it'll be interesting to see how they try to weave
grogu into the idea of the prophecy of the chosen
one of the force bringing balance to the force
but speaking of which ahsoka does clarify some of
the details about where grogu actually came from
originally before he arrived at the jedi temple he
did spend the majority of his life at the temple
before order 66 but he's not a clone of yoda he's
just another member of yoda and yaddle's species
ahsoka kind of omits any mention of yaddle in the
episode fans were kind of wondering about that so
press f in the chat to pay respects to yattle
yaddle disappeared after phantom menace mostly
behind the scenes because george lucas wanted to
focus more on yoda in the story and they didn't
want to have to deal with her and they were kind
of unhappy with how the physical puppet models
turned out for both yoda and yattle so when they
got to attack of the clones george lucas just did
yoda as a cg model then eventually wound up going
back in full blown red conning phantom menace with
cg yoda so the main reason why you didn't see
yaddle in attack of the clones is mostly just
because they wanted to save money because it was
way more expensive to do the cg yoda she wound
up stepping down from the jedi council survived
order 66 and then she just got mentioned again
during the star wars jedi fallen order game sort
of laying the track work to explain how she could
have possibly survived and is still alive out
somewhere in the galaxy hiding it's sort of a mace
windu kind of situation like if you don't see the
body technically they're still alive some people
thought that yoda's race were originally supposed
to be the wills because the original star wars
script read from the journal of the wills they
were sort of meant to be the canonical guardians
of the force and keepers of all knowledge they're
the ones who talk qui-gon jinn how to become a
force ghost but here's the thing this is actually
kind of relevant to recent easter eggs on the
mandalorian with midichlorians originally george
lucas said that he actually intended for the wills
to be the midichlorians microscopic organisms
and had he made the sequel trilogy movies himself
instead of selling star wars to disney he had
intended on getting more into that concept during
the sequel movies whether you like that idea or
not he was essentially going to double down on
midichlorians but in that way anakin skywalker
child of the midichlorians the force the will
of the force would have been a child born of the
wills and just brought the term in shmee skywalker
as a surrogate now the way that grogu explains his
history during the episode through ahsoka kind of
translating for him he was a very very young child
when he arrived at the temple he doesn't have
memories of his time before the temple so we don't
know if he was also a child of the wills conceived
the same way that anakin was typically the jedi
would bring force sensitive children to the temple
to be trained when they were between the ages
of like two and four older than that they would
always say would be too old that's why anakin
skywalker was quote unquote too old to be trained
that also gets into the idea that ahsoka talks
about during the episode forming attachments and
what that can do to fully train jedi talking
about anakin skywalker's turn to darth vader
so regardless of who grogu was born of which other
members of yoda's species he was too young to have
formed an attachment to them before he was brought
to the temple but it doesn't really matter because
now he's already formed that father-son attachment
to mando so grogu was actually at the jedi temple
before anakin skywalker arrived in phantom menace
so you have to picture an even smaller version of
grogu in the background inside of these other
rooms in the temple snatching cookies with the
force while this is all going on during attack
of the clones ahsoka said that he was trained by
many jedi masters at the temple that's because
he was at the temple for so long before order
66 in the perch it also confirms he's much more
intelligent that he lets on i think we suspected
this after season one like he was just pretending
to be a little child but he's 50 years old so
even if physically he seems like a child mentally
he's had all that time to learn all those things
but this also does confirm that he trained under
master yoda and probably trained under yaddle at
some point to or at least knew them you have
to imagine that members of yoda's species
are so rare around the galaxy that yoda himself
probably had a vested interest in helping his race
survive so he would probably go crazy any time a
new member of his species was found but as ahsoka
goes on to say grogu's memories are somewhat
incomplete because of the trauma of order 66 and
the time he's been hiding during the events of the
original trilogy so he only remembers that when
the emperor activated order 66 and sent anakin
skywalker who had newly been minted as darth vader
to kill all the jedi at the temple including the
younglings everyone press f in the chat for them
someone grabbed groku rescuing him taking him into
hiding he doesn't say who or he doesn't remember
i think mostly because they'll reveal who that
is later on the series maybe with a flashback or
they'll just have him tell someone as he remembers
more things about his history it could have only
been one of a number of few characters i'll
explain in a second because it would have had to
have been a jedi or a jedi master who was at the
temple during order 66 when anakin was attacking
in most of the jedi order like 90 percent of
them were either off planet or in other places
on coruscant in the case of mace windu in the
jedi masters that went for emperor palpatine
and unless dave filoni and jon favreau want to
take another character from legends and bring
them back into canon and say that they were at
the temple and rescued him the biggest character
right now canonically who was there and who
survived order 66 was actually jocasta nu the jedi
librarian canonically after the purge she went
into hiding and started hoarding jedi holocrons
in an attempt to create a new jedi school for
anyone who survived the purge or other new
force-sensitive children that would pop up around
the galaxy she also possessed a long list of
force-sensitive children that the jedi order were
getting ready to go bring in before order 66 went
down but just given all the details that we know
right now unless dave filoni and john favreau want
to throw us a curveball it's possible that jocasta
grabbed grogu in the chaos of anakin's attack and
was able to take him into hiding with her and
just keep him safe when she eventually went on
the run from darth vader and the inquisitors and
these people who mando was hired to take him from
who he kills during the pilot episode were just
hired guns that were loyal to the jedi order not
jedi themselves just people that she had arranged
to help protect him after her death but because
there's so many people asking about mace windu
and yattle right now yes it's totally possible
that yaddle helped protect him and just came back
and they'll work her back into the cannon somehow
or mace windu who possibly survived could have
somehow rescued him between the time he fell out
of palpatine's office and anakin made it to the
jedi temple to attack all the jedi samuel jackson
was even pitching himself for how mace windu could
come back during celebration 2017 a couple years
ago while you're all sitting there i know you're
all in my corner on this we know jedis can fall
from incredible heights and survive so apparently
i am not dead miss windu is awaiting his return
let's make it happen there's so many theories
about what happened to his character you just
have to remember that unless you see a body no
one is ever perma-dead that's not just star wars
rules or science fiction rules that's movie rules
in general i will do a new video about the jedi
temple on taithon that they're going to in which
jedi ahsoka was referring to that would answer the
beacon jedi or potential sith that should post in
the next couple of days also be doing a video for
the ahsoka vs grand admiral thrawn spin-off series
probably tomorrow and i'll explain how that plot
crosses over with the mandalorian series and when
they'll get into more of that thrawn story and the
Bo Katan versus moff gideon stuff everything
is connected but post all your theories in the
comments who was that jedi who rescued grogu
from the temple during order 66 everyone click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 5
ahsoka tano video and click here for my new grand
admiral thrawn mandalorian video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!